i'm joined today by writer and director
Jonathan Sheldon whose new film is swing
state a political comedy about a DJ who
successfully games the system by
pretending to be a right-wing radio host
and becomes an overnight sensation
Jonathan it's so great to talk to you
how'd you first conceived of this film
thanks David good to be on your show and
thanks for having me you know I started
the script about 10 years ago and what
came to mind was that there was a
star-making machinery happening
especially on the right side of the
political aisle where they were creating
celebrities through AM radio and fox
news almost exclusively through those
two mediums and I thought it would be
interesting from you know it follow a
character who was a political or
left-leaning but definitely not a right
winger and two for him to jump into that
crew and stir it up and it play it as if
he was one of them and to see how far he
could get away with his uh what he
thought would be a one-time lark and
what he creates is this character this
fictitious character that's bigger than
himself what's so funny about it is I've
had conversations with people the
commercial radio industry who said you
know David it would be interesting if
you just decided to be a right winger
and it would be fascinating how quickly
they put many many radio people
predicted I would be sort of embraced by
the right is just having sort of seen
the light and very uncritically
accepting the idea that I became uh a
right winger and you sort of build that
idea into the film where their
discussions even like for example
there's a character who is the the
equivalent of an Ann Coulter named Ann
Alcott and there's actually a discussion
between she had the supposed right-wing
radio host about his political positions
and which are sort of acceptable because
he's playing this conservative character
do what what's the broader commentary
that you're making about right wing
radio through that lens
what I noticed when I started writing
the script and I think it's cut it's an
obvious observation is that the more
outlandish you are the more on the
margins the more you throw a Molotov
cocktail intellectually into a crowd of
people the more reaction you get so the
stars that were coming up on the right
when you sort of have this coalescing of
AM radio and Fox News were the most that
would come up with the most Molotov
cocktail like ideas and they would put
that forth in books and talking points
and I mean that's true of celebrity in
general it's celebrity in general we
gravitate towards people who are the
most outlandish but when you mix up with
politics it starts to get very
interesting and I thought from a movies
perspective let's look look at a
character who goes so far it would seem
absurd to him on paper that any moment
by this but let's keep pushing it and
pushing it and he would do it in such a
sort of double entendre way that it
could be read you know could be
misinterpreted or interpreted however
you wanted to hear it so that was you
know that was sort of the idea with them
with looking at celebrity in politics I
think that as good as the sort of
caricatures of the right-wing media
people are and there's a bill o'reilly
equivalent equivalent there's an homage
to sean hannity's Hannah ties by talking
about fernet eyes all that stuff is done
really well but what I found actually
most precise and accurate was the
representation of the radio executives
and the company in the film is called
all channel which I I think we can all
figure out what big radio company that
that sort of a parody of the those
characters and and the sort of slight
characterization of the traditional
radio executive was so good I'm curious
where you got that and and how you you
built up the background for those
characters yeah that's interesting
question because that to me is what
makes the movie interesting because you
have the capitalist interests of the
radio station which are really what's
driving this whole political sideshow so
the radio station wants these stars to
exist the corporate company wants these
stars to exist because it's like that's
their Ray Kroc idea that's their big map
that they can you know make a million
times over once you get a celebrity you
can you know you can satellite it to the
world so and their interests are yet I
think most interesting maybe in the film
because they have a political bent we
assume that their right of center but
they're really just want to make a
really a great uh killing in it you want
their business to be successful so their
marketing and pushing in and the fact
that this guy comes out of nowhere and
he's he's creating a spike in ratings is
all the more exciting for them so that
does forgive whatever he says and create
a pathway for him to be successful
because you know he's doing for what
what they need him to do it from the
business landscape I don't actually
think that the concept of a sort of
pretend character that is being played
is actually that far off I've told the
story numerous times of having met alex
jones from infowars at a talk radio
conference and you know i don't know the
guy at all other than this conversation
be beyond what I see on on YouTube but
there was every indication in the
conversation that I participated in with
him that he clearly is playing a
character he doesn't believe I don't
know what percentage but a lot of the
stuff that he says and I actually think
that it's not that crazy of an idea the
degree to which it exists in the film
swing state maybe is taking it further
but i think that there's actually real
elements of this and in terms of many
media hosts that we see on a daily basis
I don't know if you agree with that I do
agree with that you know what I go back
to is the wali George show which was in
the 80s and it was a sort of a political
show with a wrestling element and Wally
George was head of the show
Los Angeles and very bombastic if
anybody wants to YouTube Wally George
they can see the antics but what he
created was an entertainment style
almost a wrestling show for politics and
he would have the bleeding heart
liberals on who always were for the most
part inarticulate and he would blow them
out of the water and it would be this
bombastic absurd moment where he would
finally kicked them off a show and the
crowd would go nuts and it was this sort
of red meat political show that was also
comedy tongue-in-cheek but you believed
that Wally George obviously held these
views like she was a serious guy in a
suit and it was this mixing of
entertainment and politics and where the
lines were we're very blurred and that
sort of a touchstone show that would
later I think be in some ways the
architecture of what we see today the
underlying film I mean is is it fair to
say that this is a romantic comedy at
its core I mean I don't even know if it
makes sense to sort of categorize it in
that way I know that romantic comedies
are not my favorite genre and but yet I
still enjoyed it but do you call this a
romantic comedy yeah so I used the
vehicle of romantic comedy the same
structure the three-act structure with
the terms of you know the conflict of a
relationship to keep the plot
interesting so it's definitely a
romantic comedy in its genre but it's
similar to Tutsi that's a romantic
comedy that's obviously more than just a
romantic comedy in Tootsie it's about a
guy pretending to be a woman who finally
learns how to be a man and I think in
our movie it's about a sort of bohemian
guy pretending to be a conservative who
finally learns how to have integrity and
also I want to point i think is worth
making david is you know the the left
character the Susan Davies the
Democratic challenger it's not as though
I wanted to make this right wing satire
I also went to lengths to create a
touch left-wing character who's so
educated and been inside her bubble that
she's really lost the heartbeat of the
people you know that that character
played by angela kinsey is uh is is very
cold and she in a lot of ways is
disconnected to what the interests of
the people are and you know as we see
through the course of the film the
elections a dead heat we're talking
about the film swing state and we've
been speaking with John Jonathan Sheldon
the writer and director of the film
what's the easiest or best way for
people to check out the film Jonathan
yeah it's on iTunes right now that's
really easy you just put in swing state
it will come right up it's on amazon and
most all VOD + digital outlets and yeah
that's where you can see it presently
fantastic thank you so much for talking
to us about it thank you David and
appreciate it